ぐらん
[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です
そう巨大 go dance ライダー#
への伊能ラグにすぐってみたぁー
やりたかったが裏にはより大きかったので
違う技で作りまーす
裏ニャーにを受けませんでしたすみません
本来こういうての企画は全部裏切らで
やろうと思ってたんで3軒の家のいろんな
ことできたじゃないです今までや際だらけ
にしたりルールだらけにしたり迷路作っ
たりもう3軒の家の豪邸の裏には広すぎて
何でもできると思ってたんですけれども
本会のオーダーサイダー計算的に無理でし
た
大きい企画お皿ための蔵にはそこで実現
可能なぐらい超巨大なウォーター
スライダー見つけました本当にできれば裏
ニャに超巨大太田使いだ作ってみたの動画
無理だったので今回こちら学校の校庭か中
このグランド貸し切って方向に超巨大
ウォータースライダーを作りたいと思い
ます今日と地質国はを連中の裏にあって
ことでいい
なったと僕夢だったんですよプールとか
行くザナイトプールどのようなクーラー
あると思いますけどモーター世代ダーって
人気で待つ時間があるんですよ
待てません一家に合田された自分で遊び方
な人も夢ないと思いますよなんとかサソリ
を実現したいということで超巨大ボウタイ
スライダーを一人で独占して遊びたいと
思います
業者の皆さんです
を築けそうですよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
陰で酒も blue sea た聞いて
頂いたのでここにもうさんとライダー作る
んですけどもやっぱり
ルールの大きなば聞いた高さ150センチ
てたいまあまあでかい水入れの塔た時間
かかるんだよっそこにも給水ポンプだっ
たりとかめっちゃ臭皇つないで水の供給は
たりとか色々含めると相当時間かかりそう
なので実際にはそれの足変な日そうです
さあ戻っさです今日はどっちかというと
組み立てをずっと待ちという感じで
ウォータースライダーの完成を待ちたいと
思います
[音楽]
手伝え
うん
やばいすそれ
[音楽]
thん
teeん
meん
ヒュー
[音楽]
do
分
[音楽]
ございますますというわけで1日経ちまし
たここで出て待ってました僕
楽しみすぎているだけでもできるという
ことですよねそうですねここまで見てない
ですよウォータースライダーといっても
その法人でつくるレベルでしょできるか
レベルでしょ
そんなすごいことないでしょ
がちょっと見てみますね
いきますよ
はいい
[音楽]
これちょっと待ってよ
tan
皆様来ちゃうしろ豚共に出てくるような気
よりでかいのこれウールタカスギィー
[音楽]
ブーバー今やないけ海峡ですこれも
ワールド寄席って子供だけで遊ぶなんか
お前た時車はないと思うんっていうわけで
地域の子どもだと呼びたかったんですけど
今回は来ちゃダメですお前たちが滑らせ
ませんちょっとあれよとくらいからすごく
泣いたか復刻横です
ティ御案内すごいなんかもうなんかもう
なってたこれすごいの中ピックが9って
言い出しですこれマジ
大丈夫俺ここまで10分の異例
meを
ジャガー
相当あるんですけども一応11.5m
らしいですっていうか
地球ペット超えておりますよ後ろでこいよ
から見て
5-早速すべてみたいと思います
もう行くしかないよね
あのさぁ
追っててよりでが来てちょっといいやなん
ですよねたとえとこじゃないよ俺なんて
優しいブリガドーンたらしっかり勝ちじゃ
ないですか
を待ってますやばいよこれだっていうふう
にさーいません入ってらっしゃいっ
こえー
一般店の下の三茶を使ったん
高さな絵だって量が4羽まあ強いまして
こいわーもうされた校舎と同じくらいの高
さ数
視界がものなさが間
に上まで来ましたうわぁ
5 a うわぁ
やべぇこれ year
ますこれですにゃーなねー
キター
俺だぜだ
ませ
んん
持っていますマジ怖いにいますねー
ああああああ
[音楽]
はい
これは
はぁ
もう1回行ってくるねめっちゃ見て楽しん
でる女刺客したの助けてまだ飛べそうな気
がするまだ飛べそう
[音楽]
やばいん
ちょっと入線しないと殺すんだかんちょう
だすれば不一致を1社はなかったけどへ
ちゃっていっ
[音楽]
tee
見てあぁ
日程フォレやばいケーズ言動を言って
ほしい私はここででもいいやってみたい
変わるよねやったねレディー効果的ああ
ああああ
さあさあさあさあんちゃんと飛ぶんだ俺
上げぶいいーやばいぞギザプッシュ通知の
裏にはですよ猫関係のユーロにあるでき
なかったので学校のにを使ってるのです
物質を結論にはということで今から猫千葉
県なんですけど範囲に及びました金には
目隠しして読んでいるのでいつもの
パターン目家の庭に何かあるなみたいな
感じで目隠しして water slide
ぽてっペまで乗せて女川目学習して今日は
落とせてみたいと思いますさて今こんなの
作ったんだよちょっターゲット後2人
ぐらい3人準備しているのでしたりずつね
学習して縁を取ってやろうと思いますでは
行こう
ございますそうじゃないですかコレなに
いきましょういきましょうやっていき
ましょう青黒しますねあて号これずっと
移行しましたっけじゃあ教育なったね
あっっ
同じ10日っては第二がん
今日も裏にはですよ
どうですか何か感じることありますあの前
にも同じようなところだったなぁ
[音楽]
粘ってたかない
たべるぞねっ
まだこういう人やり
やってんだこれ多分あっ惚れやってんな何
ハイサイドでともう戦負けでみますかはい
[音楽]
もう全部いいんゼロスから持ったいっ
もーさい付
もうちょい
花粉が本剤も追加なと思えるモーゼらしい
本尊の文殊山5 the power
[音楽]
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワン
いいけどあけよろ
ああああああ
[音楽]
なんにも何もないね
もないよまだ何もないからは何もない
でお前は何もないからねこれは何もない
からこれだけじゃないからねっはかなり前
からあるからねで上がらないも大丈夫が
いいか言って
んぬーんそのまっすぐ行こうか土井くださ
いっ
ああああ
ああ
ああああああ
わーわー
verse 1
ああああああ
バーバー
あああああっはぁああああ
caniはっはっはっ
ん
うわぁ
スタンバイの仕方をにいいですよねなーん
だよああ
あああああ
もっとは曇っちゃうけつッ
入った
もう着はもうじゃないので覗いかごっちゃ
ごちゃんじゃ
今朝ねえねえから見方をするの
いやー
ああああああ
[音楽]
goo
ていた
pou
dou
[音楽]
doume
あっ
はーる
ハアハアハア
なぜかぞを絶えずライダー
me
[音楽]
goo
母の貼って行く一番面白いこれが